[waves crashing]
[helicopter sounds]
You have to be pretty top
notch in your profession
just to survive it all.
You get heavy turbulence.
You've got to slow
the aircraft down,
because you could have
structural failure.
Losing a wing
wouldn't be much fun.
A North Atlantic
storm in November.
It's a pretty impressive
event, to put it mildly.
My name is John
Raymond Boulanger.
I'm what you would
call a mercenary pilot.
I fly for hire to he
who pays the most.
I had 4,343 kilos of cocaine,
and I was flying from Colombia
directly to Canada.
Normally, the flight would be
about nine hours, give or take.
But I ran into this storm for
about 45 minutes or an hour
before I broke out.
And, lo and behold,
there were the FATs.
[jet engine sounds]
Then they were off to my rear.
And the other guy came up close
beside us and flying around me,
making signals to go down.
I just waved to them.
They can't shoot at you.
But they were
running out of gas.
We would just time
the guy and say,
OK, how long is it going
to be before they're
going to run out?
It was interesting.
He gave us a nice little show.
I went down to treetop level.
I flew the rest of
the way treetop level,
below radar so nobody knew
where the airplane was.
The authorities put out an
alert to all the airports.
There's a big white Convair
somewhere in Canada,
if anybody sought to report it.
I should have arrived around
6 o'clock in the morning
but I arrived at
quarter to nine instead.
I was standing
out on the runway,
waiting for the crew hired
to go and do the pick up.
We looked all over the
place, couldn't figure out
where the hell these guys were.
Turns out they had been there
since 3:00 in the morning.
At around 7:30, they decided I
wasn't coming, and they left.
So anyway, I started
walking, and a truck went by.
I hitchhiked, and he gave
me a lift all the way down
to the lumber camp.
And that's where I was
when the RCMP arrived
by helicopter,
because the police
had blocked off all the roads.
So they asked, what's
in the airplane?
I said, "Cocaine."
He says, how much?
I says, "A lot."
It's being touted
as the biggest
drug bust in Canadian history
and probably the most dramatic.
[suspenseful music]
CHRIS FEISTL: The seizure of
4,300 kilos of cocaine really
reverberated through DEA.
That's a staggering amount of
cocaine, coupled with the fact
that it was flown directly from
the north coast of Colombia
into Canada.
JOHN RAYMOND BOULANGER: I would
have made around 45 million.
It's a pretty good payday
for one day's work.
That's not bad.
I was arrested, pled
guilty, and got 23 years.
That was it, and
I became famous.
But I take things with
a grain of salt. It was,
and I believe it still is, the
biggest bust ever in Canada.